Okay,
we should be live here.
Hello. Let me just set our title and
stuff.
Excuse me. All right, I will switch the
title over
or the stream over. Hey, Jess.
Excuse me. I just got out of the shower.
Okay, I'm good. I think I'm good.
I'm at Volo.
Let's
Couple little things we've been playing
with.
This is just me fishing for things.
Don't worry about this. This doesn't
really matter.
I guess we were still looking at um
like what in constellation
Yeah, this is so misleading though,
isn't it?
I'm actually Let's see. Is Volo around?
I thought we would. Well, he may or may
not be around. Um, if he is around, I
want to go over the Runescape ends
like
Huh?
Well, actually,
let's not do that. Let's Let's keep our
history clean. There's no reason to not
just merge this.
This is a nice plot, but you know, this
probably is better to just stick on um
I think I know what's going to happen
here.
Well, the these are actually pretty
cool, right?
I don't think so. Right? Because like
why is this any different from um
What is on the y ais? Perf, which is
supposed to be one normalized, but a
couple N's have um normalization errors.
I'm just kind of I like I'm just fishing
for interesting visualizations is all
I'm doing here.
I'm just fishing for like what we should
show.
Don't you guys think that this is
cooler?
So these are the params.
This is the size of the net. This is the
number of flops spent on training. But
this is for the
optimal
I actually think it will probably be
better under flops.
That's pretty cool.
Any
Yeah, I'm a little sketched with this.
Let's see.
It didn't help on 5090.
That very well could be a difference in
your CPU, dude.
you know, depending on um your CPU,
memory bandwidth, stuff like that.
I mean, generally for simple
environments that like for very simple
environments, yes, CUDA is going to be
faster, but it's also much more
complicated.
So, I think it's generally only worth it
like it's not we don't want every
environment as CUDA.
It's only going to be worth it for
specific ends.
10 to 20 minutes and 1590.
Fair enough. If you want to push that,
I still like that could be a very useful
end for sure.
I definitely need to run some sanity
checks and such.
I think I prefer the flops one.
yeah so if you want to have this to be a
cuda end there are two issues convert at
the moment right
so one is that um unless you ship both.
It can't go on the website.
You have to maintain both if you want it
on the website at the moment, unless we
have a way around that.
Um,
I guess that is the main issue depending
on the quality of the code to be fair.
The main addition of complexity is
having to maintain two versions.
Where's Valo? Man, I thought we were
going to review. Uh
I think this will be a nice simple
addition to constellation.
We will grab Kinvert's changes as well,
except I don't like the way that he did
the ring to highlight stuff. I think
it's doesn't fit the the theme.
It doesn't fit the theme. We're going to
do it slightly different.
Okay,
not Bad.
What am I working on? Just like
pre-release tweaks for um 5.0. Generally
currently doing a couple things with the
dashboard. This doesn't have any data
loaded into it. It'll look cool in a
second as soon as I load the data in.
And um
Make sure we get uh
these changes pulled in.
Huh?
I hate GitHub, man.
the game on your website feels rigged.
Which one?
Oh, this.
Yeah, this is not rigged. It's just
really, really hard.
It's not rigged in any way. It's
literally just that like it's very
precise. So, I mean, this kind of shows
you that like a little tiny neural net
can play this perfectly.
This kind of just shows you how cool RL
is, right?
This is not like some sophisticated
planning algorithm or some like model
predictive control.
This is just like straight RL.
No, it doesn't learn from how you play.
It just learns by it just plays a whole
bunch of games against itself or against
the scripted bot depending how you set
it up on its own and then it learns to
play from
currently learning this stuff. I have
articles on my site or on my uh my X
page rather.
If you just click here, the articles tab
is uh pretty much everything you need to
get started.
What is happening?
seen this drone end for instance. This
one's cool.
what's going on today. Uh, I got to
merge a few things. We've got some
optimizations for a few M. Basically,
it's just pre-release work.
The one thing I did is I'm I am sort of
on the side because I get bored with
pre-release work is I kind of am like
fishing for updates or like fishing for
a couple improvements. It looks like we
have a reasonable attention colonel. I
have to go through it,
which could be cool.
What's my research about? Uh, we train
tiny models on really high performance
simulations
and we get superhuman performance.
Like we use games for research, but it's
not just games, right? We've got drones,
we've got driving, we've got other
scientific stuff in here.
My PhD thesis was on massively multi-
aent intelligence. Uh specifically as
well, building simulators that are
compatible with RL, dealing with all the
infrastructure problems that arise and
then figuring out algorithmic and
architecture changes needed.
So the attention kernel would be for
just like encoders, I would think.
It would be for anywhere that you need
um
you wouldn't do a temporal attention to
be clear. It would be for observations.
I don't think temporal attention would
ever really make any sense.
Marov doesn't matter. It's that that's
not the problem with attention. The
problem with attention is that
your your rollouts for RL where you're
collecting data are basically inference
mode for a language model.
And it's actually even worse because you
have to loop back and forth with the
environment.
So you want to have something that's
like a onestep O of one or like whatever
inference. You don't want to have O of
N.
It's much less bad when you're already
doing stuff over entities.
squared.
Uh, it's n squared where you would
already have n though.
It's a little tricky to explain.
But essentially,
you already have to load all that data
in anyways. You add some compute
pressure, but you're already memory
bound anyways.
Whereas in the other case, it causes you
to load in a factor of n more data.
A markup doesn't Yeah, we just honestly
like all of the MDP formalism we
essentially ignore. It's not useful.
It's not even a correct model in most
cases. Like first of all, stuff's
partially observed and second of all,
the POM DP formulism which already is
not particularly useful even
theoretically goes out the window with
multiple agents.
We honestly just look at it as learning
through interaction.
And we typically model this in
Uh we model this using games.
many M's break that.
But the thing is it doesn't matter like
In general, the set of properties that
are like like difficult to model from a
theoretical perspective are not at all
the same set of properties that are
difficult to actually Turn.
Yeah, it's Well, we need axes on these,
don't we?
Yeah, right. Convert. It's like rather
than just drawing a um
a big circle
No. No. That would be a different
shader. That's not worth it.
Oops. Hang on a second. Let me let me
deal with one thing here.
I'll be right back, guys. One sec.
Just
All right, hang on a sec, guys. I'm
seeing whether I I'm getting breakfast
or not.
Oh, Vol is going to be 30 to 45 minutes,
guys.
Rotation mount works. Yep, this works.
Uh Here's the plan. I got to go grab
food because uh I'm going to have to
chat with Vo after this. Um but that's
going to be fun. I think we'll probably
do that on stream as well. Volo has all
the Runescape environments. He's got
Colosseum, he's got Inferno, he's got a
whole big port of stuff. So, we're going
to be looking through that and seeing
what we can do with it. That should be a
fun time. So, if you want to see that,
dot back by in about 45 minutes.
I merged it. Crit. I have to test it. I
will be back in about 45 minutes.